so I told you yesterday Donald Trump was
flying to Mexico and he was going to
meet with the Mexican president Nieto
did they discuss this wall that Trump
wants to build will here's what we do
know they had this joint press
conference following this visit in
Mexico City the optics of it were truly
strange because you had a woman who
compared to Trump's size looked
physically very very small holding
papers and basically doing live
translation right into Trump's ear into
English of the speech that the Mexican
president was giving in Trump had one of
the most arrogant and pompous looks I've
maybe ever seen even on trump's face
that this woman was was giving him the
live translation uh and Trump told
reporters after the meeting we did
discuss the wall we didn't discuss
payment of the wall that will be for a
later date
this was a preliminary meeting I think
it was an excellent meeting the problem
is that is not at all the way that the
Mexican president recalls it going on to
Twitter the Mexican president said and
I'm showing you here the tweet uh in
Spanish saying at the beginning of the
conversation with Donald Trump I made
clear that Mexico will not pay for the
wall speaking in absolutely direct terms
and Jason you actually read some of the
other tweets from the Mexican president
stream it there was no ambiguity here I
mean that he but he he seems to have
told in detail the way this conversation
went and part of that was we're not
paying for the wall exactly he said they
they had a good conversation but it was
you know very clear he said the first
thing I said to the man we're not
building your wall so Donald Trump walks
in any jokes and then he lies about it
he's been running this campaign on he
can make deals and he showed up and and
uh did not make one of these major deals
he didn't get what he's been promising
what every normal person knew he was
never going to get which is Mexico to
pay to build the wall that would be on
this side of the us-mexico border and
Trump's campaign is sort of talking
about this as oval it was it was not
even meant to be a discussion about
was going to pay for the wall Rachel
Trump flies to Mexico on this private
jet after bragging for more than a year
I'm gonna make Mexico pay for the wall
he arrives he's greeted by Mexican
dignitaries and members of uh of the
president's uh president's staff and so
on and so forth he gets escorted to this
well-publicized meeting with the Mexican
president and then the Mexican president
says we are not paying for your wall not
exactly the image of the alpha male
Trump making deals is it right and this
is kind of a man who says okay I'm the
face of the art of the deal so now is he
going to say okay I'm gonna meet with
NAFTA I'm going to undo trade deals and
I'm going to say everything worked out
but I'm gonna come back and I'm going to
lie about is that gonna kind of be the
trajectory for him if he becomes
president of course this is a total
preview if you have it all been
hypnotised by Trump's idea that as soon
as he's president everybody will respect
him and he's going to show up and and
throw his weight around and it's just
all gonna happen for him
we already saw a preview of it he went
to Mexico after touting a policy for
more than a year and straight up the
Mexican president says it's just not
happening
and then from comes out of it and then
he lies and gets called out by the first
foreign leader or or at least one of the
more prominent foreign leaders that he
has met with since officially becoming
the Republican nominee this is not
acting presidential and I you know
yesterday I said I think that this is a
total backfire for the Mexican president
because he claims not to like Donald
Trump but he is in some way legitimizing
Donald Trump by inviting him to come to
Mexico and have this official meeting I
kind of take that back because this has
backfired so drastically on Donald Trump
where now he looks like the guy who
can't get anything done and the Mexican
president who by and large has been
having approval ratings problems Rachel
now he is the guy who brought big bad
Trump in his private jet to his own
country and in his own home field told
them just not happening Don it is not
happening and I would be embarrassed if
I was Donald Trump right
well did he believe that when he invited
Hillary and Trump that Trump was
actually going to show up or did he
think that the opposite was going to
happen we speculated a little bit about
that yesterday Jason and my initial
thought was I'll invite them both that
is Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump and
then uh Hillary hopefully will show up
and that will make me look really really
great but Trump isn't gonna do it
because it has been so difficult and
we've had this frayed relationship so on
and so forth I think that that was not
necessarily the way this was not
necessarily the way the Mexican
president was hoping it would happen but
I have to tell you it worked out pretty
damn well for him yeah I think if the
the end of the day the story here is
that Trump goes down there he lies about
what what happens he says the president
we didn't talk about this yes that's not
we talked about at all and then the you
know at the end the president told tell
the truth you can see through his tweets
he's he's saying was going on I I
believe the MEK some President more than
Trump here certainly here is sort of
it's his using his a little taste of his
own medicine Trump has made it a policy
of making comments about all sorts of
stuff through Twitter and now he has
been turned into the subservient guy who
got on his plane at the request of the
Mexican president and flew down to
Mexico and really really got embarrassed